good evening Mike Fred good evening
Nancy Pelosi is already looking beyond
this year's midterm election to taking
back the speaker's gavel Pelosi told The
Boston Globe quote we will win I will
run for speaker I feel confident about
it and my members due to her bravado
didn't stop there it's important that it
not be five white guys at the table no
offense I have no intention of walking
away from that table sources at the
National Republican Congressional
Committee say they're taking those
Pelosi comments and already working on
ads like this one there's a no play in
the playbook on the Republican side that
seemed to work here again and that was
tying John Asaf to Nancy Pelosi in
Georgia they were and in some part
they're running against Nancy Pelosi and
it's working thank you
we're continuing to fail as your party's
leader Pelosi's campaign office
announced this week she raised 16.1
million dollars in the first quarter
even so some rank-and-file members like
Massachusetts congressman Seth Moulton
say Democrats should not be looking
backwards they should be looking forward
quote I think there's a strong desire
out there in America for new leadership
in Washington not just getting rid of
Republicans but getting new leadership
in the Democratic Party and some of the
candidates Democrats need to win for
their party to take back the house are
signaling they want to lose leadership
to for example ELISA Slaton and Michigan
who says when it comes to Speaker she
wants quote someone who best represents
my district and what we care about here
and I believe that's a new generation of
leaders Pelosi is already introducing
colleagues at events saying the
committee's they will chair in the new
Congress Republicans and some of our
fellow Democrats are saying not so fast